l'inspecteur municipal sylvain girard
est aux aguets ces jours ci chaque matin
sa journée de travail commence au bord
du lac champlain 60 est pratiquement
voisins
on est un petit peu plus haut que le
seuil d'inondation mineure
on est prêt nous pour toute éventualité
le dépendamment si l'eau continue de
monter ou si les vents changent de
direction donc on on est on est prêt les
riverains du coin sont aussi sur le qui
vive
il y a quelques jours de fortes vagues
ont ils ont dit leur terrain
heureusement les grands vents ont cessé
il ou s'est retiré j'ai paniqué parce
que ça monte et ça ça fait environ deux
heures puis louer cette année sur le
terrain alentour décidera ça a commencé
ici ça monte et dole
puis 16 continuellement ça s'en allait
cette dame de 86 ans a elle aussi
ressenti de l'inquiétude les mauvais
souvenirs de 2011 sont toujours bien
présent dans l'esprit des résidents
alors ici on était à deux pieds d'eau
environ s'étaient bordel au printemps
2011 le lac champlain a carrément envahi
leur maison toute la région du haut
richelieu a subi l'effet de ces crues
historiques
les habitants de certains quartiers
comme celui ci sont restées les pieds
dans l'eau pendant six semaines
tous les bâtiments qui ont été
endommagés assez sérieusement 2011 on
obliger ces gens alors à s'immuniser la
maison à monter la maison c'est avec et
axa devait environ dix mille dards à sa
maison rénovée a été relevé de 1 m le
solage n'a aucune fenêtre ou qu'une
ouverture le sous sol est désormais un
vide sanitaire de 2 mètres de profondeur
ça nous fait beaucoup de démarches
montella qu'alex se arriverai a dû lui
aussi tenir compte des nouvelles normes
municipales avant de songer à se
reconstruire
j'ai tout démoli le première étage avec
le plancher et j'ai relevé le niveau du
plancher de verre suppose le but vide
sanitaire et social rien éliminer le
problème parce qu'on va s'en sortir
assez bien si il vante pas trop
le maire de venise en québec et serait
actuellement puisqu'une bonne partie des
maisons vulnérables sont désormais
protégés ce chemin là l'europe aussi par
deux films année gilles imaginez vous de
vos pieds un plus beau avec le passé
par-dessus bst aller sur 47 maisons
inondées c'était une façon de sortir 47
maisons et le prix certains verront
250000 pour faire ce rappel en 2011
s'était plaint le maire landry était aux
premières loges lors des crues de 2011
il a réussi à sauver un quartier complet
en faisant relever d'urgence une route
qui agit maintenant comme une digue de
protection et y'a pas quelles solutions
vous avez communes et les maisons sur
pilotis
vous allez remonter dessalage en et des
salages pour remonter ça coûte environ
12 14 mai alors c'est bien moins cher qu
200 habitants se faire une raison les
gens s'aiment seul bord de l'eau donc on
devrait peut-être arriver à cela
comme tout le monde madame désilets et
ses voisins seulement 2,6 la nature leur
réserve encore de mauvaises surprises
pour l'instant ils dorment bien confiant
que leur rénovation
les protège encore un temps contre les
mauvais printemps